- [Instructor] So let's imagine
that each of these little circles here,
represent a member of
a population of bugs.
And, we have two different
population of bugs.
You could view this as population one
on the left side of this orange line
and population two on the
right side of this orange line.
And these bugs, we're gonna think about
just one trait, their color,
because it's easy to visualize.
And let's say that their color
generally helps them
camouflage from predators.
So this kind of cloudy, white,
and black, and green layer,
that's maybe the
environment that they're in,
where you might find them.
Maybe it's the surface
of a moss covered tree
or something like that.
And these are two separate populations
of maybe a related species,
or maybe the same species,
but they're two different populations
that are not intermixing.
Now the first question is,
which of these these populations
has more genetic diversity?
Well, on the left here,
we see that they're all the same color.
It looks like a pretty useful color.
It seems to hide them pretty well,
camouflaged them pretty well.
On the right here, it's
clear that there's more
different types of colors.
Some of them are roughly the same color
as what we see on the left hand side,
but some of them are good bit darker
and some of them are good bit lighter.
So the one on the right,
the population on the
right has more diversity.
Now, one could argue that some
of these very bright circles
or some of these darker circles,
might be more susceptible to predators,
and that actually might be the case.
But what we're gonna think
about in this video is not
how many members of the population
may be more or less
susceptible to predators,
what we're gonna think about is,
does the diversity help us
when there might be some type
of changes to the environment?
Does it make the population
as a whole more resilient?
I'm not talking about
any individual member of the population.
And to imagine that, let's imagine
that there's some type
of environmental change,
maybe there's pollution in the area
that makes the surfaces
that these little bugs
have to live on a good bit darker.
So maybe the surfaces look like this.
So now what's likely to happen?
Well, in this reality, all of
the bugs on our left hand side
are now more visible to predators.
And so you can imagine the predators
might be able to pick
off a lot more of them.
Or in an extreme case,
maybe able to finish
them off all together,
while on the right some of
the members of the population
are easier to pick off,
like that one, and that one,
and that one, and that one.
While some other members of the population
are even more camouflaged
than they were before.
Like that one, and that one, and that one.
And so the population
because of its diversity,
yes, a lot of them might die off,
they might be picked off by predators,
but it looks like there's a
subset of the right population,
that is gonna be more likely to survive
and then they can continue to reproduce.
And so you won't have the
entire population dying off.
And you could imagine
it the other way around.
Let's say instead of the
environment getting somehow darker,
imagine if the environment
got somehow lighter,
something like that?
Well, you see a similar phenomenon.
All the ones on the left are
now very similarly visible,
and maybe the predators
could pick them off,
while on the right,
some of them have become
a lot more visible.
In this case the darker
ones are now super-visible.
The predators might be
able to pick them off
and even some of the medium colored.
But there's a good number of them
that now blend in quite well,
like that one, and that one,
and I can't even see them that well,
they're blending in so well.
And so once again,
there's certain members of the populations
that because of this more diversity,
they are more likely to be able to survive
some type of environmental perturbation.
And so since they are
more likely to survive,
the entire population is
less likely to be killed off.
So the population as a
whole is more resilient.
Not saying that every
member of the population
is more resilient, but
the population as a whole.
So the general takeaway here is that
more diversity leads to more
environmental resilience,
or resilience to changes
in the environment.
Once again, we're not talking
about every individual member
of the population being more resilient.
We're talking about the
population as a whole
being able to survive in some way,
and then keep carrying on.